U.S. PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN,
VOWING TO HUNT DOWN, AND PUNISH
THOSE RESPONSIBLE, FOR THE
DEADLY KABUL ATTACK.
THE ISLAMIC STATE AFFILIATE,
ISIS-K, CLAIMING IT IS BEHIND
THE SUICIDE BLAST, WHICH KILLED
MORE THAN 13 U.S. SERVICE
MEMBERS, AND DOZENS OF AFGHANS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, SAYING THAT
THE U.S. WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH
EVACUATIONS, BUT MADE IT CLEAR,
THE NATION WILL NEITHER FORGIVE,
NOR FORGET.
>> WE WILL NOT BE DETERRED BY
TERRORISTS.
WE WILL NOT STOP OUR MISSION,
AND WE WILL NOT CONTINUE THE
EVACUATION.
THEY DEVELOP OPERATIONAL
COMMANDERS TO STRIKE ISIS-K
ASSETS, AND FACILITIES.
WE RESPOND WITH THE FORCE OF
PRECISION, AND IT IS A MOMENT
OF OUR CHOOSING.
>> LOOK FOR A CLOSER LOOK, AND
IT JOINS US NOW FROM ISTANBUL.
SHE EXTENSIVELY COVERS US THE
RISE, AND FALL, OF ISIS IN
IRAQ.
JOE, ISIS-K CARRIED OUT THE
DEVASTATING ATTACKS, AND THEY
TALKED ABOUT SCHOOLGIRLS,
MATERNITY HOSPITALS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THEIR
CAPABILITIES IN AFGHANISTAN FOR
THE MOMENT?
>> MICHAEL, THEY HAVE BEEN A
THREAT, A MAJOR THREAT,
ACCORDING TO U.S. OFFICIALS IN
THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE BEEN THE TARGET OF
MILITARY OPERATIONS,
COUNTER-TERRORISM OPERATIONS IN
THE COUNTRY, AND AS YOU
MENTIONED, WE'VE SEEN THOSE
DEVASTATING ATTACKS SINCE 2016.
IN RECENT MONTHS, THEY'VE SHOWN
THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE THEIR
TARGETS.
DO Q ATTACKS, WHEREVER, AND
WHATEVER, THEY WANT.
THEY'VE REMAINED A SERIOUS
THREAT IN THE COUNTRY.
SO, WHEN IT COMES TO NUMBERS,
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF ESTIMATE,
SOMETHING LIKE ONE, THOUSAND TO
1500.
BUT, WHAT REALLY HAS CONCERNED
OFFICIALS, AND WE'VE HEARD THIS
FROM U.S. MILITARY OFFICIALS
ARE AS PRESIDENT BIDEN.
.
>> THESE PRISON BREAKS TO SEE
IN AFGHANISTAN, AS THE TALIBAN
SWEPT ACROSS THE COUNTRY, I SEE
THOUSANDS OF TO HAVE JOINED THE
RANKS OF THESE GROUPS.
REALLY RAISING CONCERNS FOR
THEIR ABILITY TO CARRY OUT MORE
OF THESE DEVASTATING ATTACKS.
WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING,
MICHAEL, IS OF COURSE, IF YOU
LOOK AT THURSDAY'S ATTACKS,
THIS WAS, AGAIN, WHAT WOULD BE
TO CRIES AS A COMPLEX WHO ARE
NATIVE ATTACK.
YOU AND I LOVE CROWDS, WHO
COVERED THESE BOMBINGS IN THE
PAST IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO IN
FLICKED MAXIMUM DAMAGE.
A THE HORROR WE SAW UNFOLD ON
THURSDAY, INFILTRATING THESE
LARGE CROWDS.
I THINK ONE THING TO KEEP AN
EYE ON, WHAT U.S. OFFICIALS MAY
SAY IN THE COMING DAYS ABOUT.
THEY ARE BOMB MAKING AND
BELICHICK'S THIS INVESTIGATION
IN TERMS OF EXPLOSIVE USE THEIR
FOREIGN DAD.
AND IF I AM NOT IN THAT CLAIM
OF RESPONSIBILITY BY THAT GROUP,
I CAN'T SAY NOT ONLY WERE THEY
TARGETING U.S. MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS, THEY'RE ALSO TARGETING,
WHAT THEY DESCRIBED AS THE
COLLABORATOR SEWER TO THE
AMERICANS.
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS ARE FACING,
RIGHT NOW, WITH THE FEARS THAT
THEY WILL BE LEFT BEHIND
MICHAEL.
>> JOMANA KARADSHEH, APPRECIATE
IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> IF THERE ARE BEHIND AN
AIRPORT ATTACK AS A CLAIM,
SUPPOSED LIKE TO DISCUSS THIS.
HE IS THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
ASIA-PACIFIC FOUNDATION, AND AN
EXPERT ON TERRORISM.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
WE'VE HEARD THE U.S. PRESIDENT,
AND OTHERS SAY, ISIS-K IS A
SWORN ENEMY OF THE TALIBAN'S
REALIZED IS MURKY, AND IN NO
WAYS HAS BEEN A KIND THERE IS
VERY FEW THAT IS BETTER, THEN
ON THE OTHER.
YOU'LL SEE SOMEONE, DO
CONTRIBUTE FOR ONE DAY, FOR
MUTUAL INTEREST, FOR
CONVERGENCE OR HAVE SIA, OUT OF
A AFGHANISTAN.
YOU WILL HAVE TO REMEMBER,
ISIS-K ARE MADE UP OF PASHTUNS,
BOTH FROM PAKISTAN, AND
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE ETHNIC, TRIBAL, CLAN
MINIATURES, WITH THE TALIBAN.
SO, IT IS A MUCH MORE NEAR THE
NEXUS THEN, PERHAPS IT'S,
LOOKING AT IT FROM A BLACK AND
WHITE PERSPECTIVE.
>> THIS ONE COMES THIS COMES OF
WHEN YOU LOOK UP CAT AND.
BUT ALSO, CHAOS ON THE GROUND.
WHAT ELSE MIGHT ISIS-K BE
LOOKING TO DO WAS A FAVOR EACH
IN CAPABILITY?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
ATTACKS THEY HAVE CARRIED OUT
OVER THE LAST YEAR, YOU
MENTIONED, THE ATTACK ON THE
MATERNITY WARD.
, AND THEY TARGETED A GIRLS
SCHOOL.
IT IS DOZENS OF YOUNG CHILDREN
WHO ARE MURDERED.
OF COURSE, NOW THIS AWFUL,
HORRIFIC ATTACK AT THE AIR
AIRLINE.
THEY WANT TO SHOW THE AFGHANS,
BUT THEY HAVE A STAKE IN
AFGHANISTAN, IS VERY DYSTOPIAN,
FUTURE.
NOW THE WEST IS LEAVING, AND
THEY WILL COMPETE CONTINUING
THE TALIBAN WITH CONTROL OF THE
COUNTRY, FORTUNATELY, AFGHAN
PEOPLE, ARE NOW SANDERS BETWEEN
THE TALIBAN ON ONE SIDE, AND
BILL ON THE OTHER.
YES, PICK OF A CHOICE >> THE
U.S. POUNDED ISIS-K,
RELENTLESSLY FOR A WHILE.
SARAH THEY WENT QUIET.
HOW MUCH OF AN IMPACT OF THE
TALIBAN'S RELEASE A, DURING
THEIR SLEEP ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I HAVE ON ISIS-K IS OPERATING
ON STREAM.
>> CERTAINLY, AND KNOW, LOOK
TEAMS WILL INCREASE AGAINST
FREE ME.
AND THE FANS, FROM VARIOUS
JAILS, ACROSS AFGHANISTAN, AS
THE TALIBAN WERE ALSO, ISIS-K
THAT IS EMERGE FROM THE
WOODWARD, BASED ON PAKISTAN.
THEIR AND MINDS ANOTHER'S, AND
YOU FOUND OUT IT'S NOT JUST THE
TALIBAN, BUT ISIS-K FIGHTERS TO.
THEN QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT
PAKISTAN'S ROLE IN ALL OF THIS.
THEY HAVEN'T JUST AIDED AND
ABETTED THE TALIBAN IN THE PAST,
BUT POSSIBLY, ISIS-K, FOR THEIR
OWN STRATEGIC REASONS, BECAUSE
THEY WOULD HAVE THIS ASPECT OF
STRATEGIC DEATH, WHERE
AFGHANISTAN.
THEN, THE CONCERN IS, WHAT ROLE
WILL PAKISTAN PLAY, IN
AFGHANISTAN'S FUTURE,
ESPECIALLY FOR WAY KOBE?
HIS GOVERNMENT WANTING TO MAKE
INTERNATIONAL RECOGNITION, AND
LEGITIMIZATION, FOR THE
TALIBAN.
BUT, HOW CAN ONE DO THAT WHEN
THEY RETAIN THESE ALL TIES WITH
ALL OF THESE TERRORIST GROUPS
TO, AMONG CIVILIANS, GO ALSO GO
LOOKING AT THE DEATH OF 13 U.S.
MARINES, WHO ARE TRYING TO SAVE
LIVES AND AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT'S A COMP